I'm Grant Tompson, the King of Random, and
I have accepted the ALS Ice bucket Challenge.
Except instead of using a bucket of regular
ice, I'm using a bucket filled with dry ice
which is about five times colder, and minus
109 degrees fahrenheit. I really have no idea
what to expect. So lets just put a little
more dry ice in here and see what happens.
It's pretty heavy.
Whoooo! Yeah!
Taste that carbonation!
Tadaaa!
So there you go, I've successfully completed
the ice bucket challenge Obviously this is
something you don't wanna duplicate at home.
Because I had a few chunks of dry ice go down
my shirt, and burn my skin. So it is dangerous.
Don't try dry ice. I would like to nominate,
Ben with NightHawkInLight, Bryan Brushwood
from ScamSchool, and Destin from Smarter Everyday.
You have 24 hours to complete this challenge.
GO!